Real estate investment can produce a constant income source,...
...rise in value and could be a good investment in the cash value of the land...
...or building you purchase.
Advisors generally warn against borrowing money to buy rental properties.
You need to have backup finances to make payments on the property when it is not rented out.
You also need to think about taxes, upkeep, and how to rent it out.
Perhaps, it's simpler to use a real estate agent, who will administrate the property for you.
This will consume some of your profits.
Surplus money that you make in the first months should be set aside for repairs.
Important is also a good insurance policy...
...because additional costs and other unforeseen situations may arise.
If you intend to buy land to sell at a later date, you have to check the land deed.
Any planned roads in the vicinity may add value but could also decrease the property value.
Research and planning are of essence.